à quand un vaccin contre le coc vide 19
partout dans le monde les scientifiques
cherchent selon la ministre française de
la recherche ne sera sans doute pas
disponibles avant 18 mois l'agencé
européenne du médicament de son côté
évoque un délai d'un an donald trump lui
la fin de l'année mais dans cette course
effrénée aux vaccins qu'en est il de la
coopération internationale on voit cela
avec un walid bennani trouver l'antidote
celui qui permettra de sauver des
millions de vies voilà l'objectif numéro
un des grands laboratoires aujourd'hui
mais gouvernement sur dallas temps de la
recette miracle
et dans cette course un sentiment semble
dominer que le meilleur gagne
oui nous avons très bien travaillé celui
qu'il obtiendra sera très fier de le
donner de le développer nous verrons ce
qui se passera
celui qui l'obtient nous pensons que
c'est génial nous allons travailler avec
eux ils ont travaillé avec nous
également
si nous l'obtenons nous allons
travailler avec eux donald trump tente
d'éteindre la dernière polémique
en effet le laboratoire français sanofi
a assuré dans un premier temps que les
états unis seront les premiers servis
si un vaccin était découvert un choix
prioritaire qui a scandalisé dans
l'hexagone et obliger l'exécutif à
réagir je viens de le rappeler à serge
weinberg qui préside sanofi cette grande
entreprise profondément française il m'a
donné toutes les assurances nécessaires
quant à la distribution en france d'un
éventuel vaccin sanofi
la chine n'est pas en reste de la
compétition mondiale et vient d'annoncer
que cinq vaccins expérimentaux antico
vite 19 et est actuellement testé sur
l'homme 2575 volontaire au total ont été
vaccinées dans le cadre de différents
projets et aucun effet indésirable
majeur n'a été rapporté
le gouvernement a ajouté que la phase 2
de tous les essais cliniques
actuellement en cours sera terminée
d'ici juillet sans donner toutefois de
date de commercialisation etats-unis
france chine mais aussi grande bretagne
à laboratoire du sud de l'angleterre
travaillent sur un vaccin qui seraient
prescrits par voie orale et pourraient
être envoyées par la poste
nous avons vraiment besoin du soutien du
gouvernement car à partir de juillet
nous devrions fabriquer des millions de
doses
ne devrions pas attendre d'avoir obtenu
l'approbation réglementaire faites le
maintenant c'est relativement peu
coûteux elle l'appui du gouvernement
l'approbation des autorités publiques
pour un de passage obligé avant la
diffusion d'un vaccin au brésil
le dernier ministre de la santé a
démissionné après des divergences avec
son président notamment sur
l'utilisation de la controversée
chloroquine pas de partage
d'informations ou de convergence à
l'échelle internationale européenne ou
encore national
et pourtant la recherche avance très
bien nous avons de bonnes raisons d'être
suffisamment optimiste quant au fait
qu'en fin de compte
certains vaccins seront efficaces
plusieurs technologies ont été abordés
ici et sont à l'étude et je serai donc
surpris si au bout du compte nous
n'aurons pas de vaccin disponibles pour
le comique 19 avec plus de 100 projets
et une dizaine d'essais cliniques en
cours l'agencé européenne du médicament
prévoit qu'un vaccin pourrait être prêt
dans un an